you know we suspected for a while that
when many of these right-wingers say
abortion is murder
they don't really mean that it's
something they say if it's convenient if
it helps them raise money now of course
some of them sincerely mean it and I
mean the voters but when you look at the
polls you see that uh support for
abortion being legal in most cases has
increased over the last 50 years quite
steadily and so intuitively there have
to be some shills out there who are only
claiming to have these positions about
abortion
to the extent that it's useful to them
politically but they don't really care
about it that much Donald Trump is a
really great example the Herschel Walker
Scandal as it's being called wherein
despite claiming to be pro-life despite
claiming that abortion is murder no
exceptions for rape incestor the life of
the mother despite saying all of those
things
he now has been credibly accused with
receipts of urging and paying one of his
ex-girlfriends uh to get an abortion
paying for one of his ex-girlfriends to
get an abortion so of course the
Republicans will now denounce Herschel
Walker right we cannot support a man who
no it's not happening it turns out
apparently they don't really care about
abortion being murder here's Dana losh
Lesh uh who says quite straightforwardly
she's a right-wing radio host I don't
care if Herschel Walker paid to abort
endangered baby eagles I want control of
the Senate so does this change anything
I I mean do you want my opinion are you
listening yeah not a damn thing oh
how many times have I said four very
important words
these four words winning is a virtue oh
what I'm about to say is in
no means a contradiction okay or a
compromise of a principle so in other
words it is that
and please keep in mind that I am
concerned about one thing and one thing
only at this point
so I don't care if Herschel Walker paid
to abort endangered baby eagles I want
control of the Senate right
if The Daily Beast story is true
you're telling me Walker used his money
to reportedly pay
some skank for an abortion and Warnock
wants to use all of our Monies to pay a
whole bunch of skanks for abortions
so the big takeaway here is a lot of
these people don't really think abortion
is murder or they do but they're willing
to vote for the murderers anyway if it's
politically convenient Republicans think
abortion is murder except when the
Senate is on the line here's Don Lemon
on CNN last night speaking to right wing
you know whatever right-wing strategist
right-wing analyst consultant Alice
Stewart
and uh this is just unbelievable it's a
whole position here because the entire
time that we've been on the air together
you said that the reason that you held
your nose and voted for Donald Trump was
because of his stance on abortion right
and now you're saying it doesn't matter
that that Herschel Walker is
hypocritical about an abortion and
allegedly has paid for one right an
abortion that it is now okay
because
of inflation so
listen guys abortion is murder but have
you seen these gas prices what I'm
saying right now if I were back in my
home state of Georgia and I had to
decide between a candidate like Herschel
Walker who may or may not have paid for
one abortion or Raphael Warnock who is
supportive of taxpayer-funded abortions
for everyone I think the the choice is
very simple Herschel Walker's policies
are more in line with Republicans and
conservatives in the state of Georgia
and moving forward this is going to be a
tremendous how do you know he's telling
you the truth about those issues if he's
not telling you the truth about abortion
we'll just have to take his word for it
like you took his word about the
abortion thing right uh wow wow and then
rounding this out is Newt Gingrich who
um talks about how Walkers deeply
committed to Christ and also has had
many concussions so I guess it's okay
what he did I don't know I talked to
Herschel about this this morning and
I've known her show a good while oh well
if you've known him for a long time then
certainly please proceed I think he's a
remarkable person I think he's the most
important Senate candidate in the
country because he'll do more to change
the Senate just by the sheer Presence by
his confidence by his deep commitment to
Christ right by the degree to which he
is you know he's been through a long
tough period he had a lot of concussions
coming out of football yeah listen you
can't blame the guy who says abortion is
murder for paying for an abortion he
could be concussed for all we know
that's Newt gingrich's take these people
are completely pathetic these people are
hypocrites these people so that I
tweeted about this and there's kind of
there's really two possibilities here
okay one they do believe abortion is
murder
they really do
they just don't care about voting for
so-called murderers as long as it keeps
a Democrat out of office that's one
possibility the second possibility is
they don't really believe abortion is
murder it's just something that they say
when it's convenient in order to raise
money and it is becoming extremely
obvious the more that this Herschel
Walker thing goes let's now talk about
the polling in that race our sponsor
magic spoon is the breakfast cereal that
tastes amazing but without the sugar
carbs and the crazy ingredients magic
spoon has taken your favorite childhood
cereals and brilliantly transformed them
into something you can feel good about
eating because each serving has zero
grams of sugar under five net carbs and
is packed with 13 grams of protein so
it'll work for keto and low carb but
it's really perfect for anyone who wants
the occasional sweet crunchy treat
without the sugar their portfolio of
eight plus unique delicious flavors
allow you to never get bored my favorite
is maple waffle but they've got the
classics like cocoa fruity frosted also
cinnamon roll blueberry muffin our
entire team has been eating magic spoon
for years we love it but if you don't
they send you all your money back it's
really easy magic spoon has been
supporting the David packman show for a
long time they always give my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below